-Welcome back to the attic
crawl space, everybody.
Now, as you may know,
there's been some speculation
online about what's behind
my tiny little door back there.
And I just want to put
one of the rumors to rest.
I do not keep my children
in there
so they won't interrupt me
while I'm filming.
For one,
that would be very cruel.
And two,
it's a shallow closet.
You would never fit
both of them.
Which is something you can tell
from eyeballing.
I didn't try.
You can't lock it
from the outside.
Look, there are
a lot of reasons.
But the main one is
it would be cruel.
Also, it's been pointed out
that the number of copies
of "The Thorn Birds" on
my side table kept increasing.
At one point there was one copy,
then two,
then a third copy seemed
to appear out of nowhere.
It was very strange.
So we had our guy
come to check it out.
He said it's pretty common
in old attic
to have an infestation of what
he called "mini-series books."
He said at one point,
there was likely an aunt
of some sort up here.
But he sprayed.
We're back down to one.
And he said everything will be
back to normal in a week or two,
while also stressing
you have to be patient
with a problem like this and,
you know, you can't rush it.
And yet while I'm being patient
with my "Thorn Birds" books,
the president is already getting
ready to reopen the economy
after a bombshell
"New York Times" report
revealed more details
about how he ignored the threat
posed by the coronavirus.
That's a segue.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As we've already detailed,
the president ignored
repeated warnings
over the course of several years
that a pandemic like this
was coming,
that it could kill
lots of people,
and that it could
devastate the economy.
Then he lied about it,
said it would go away,
pushed a miracle cure
that doctors have said
could have potentially
lethal side effects,
and is now telling everyone
things could just
go back to normal after
tens of thousands have died
and 17 million
have lost their jobs,
or as the president put it...
-We have done a job the likes
of which nobody has seen.
And you should say
"Congratulations. Great job."
instead of being, uh, so horrid
in the way you ask a question.
-Well, I will congratulate you
on bringing back
the word "horrid."
Really nice work on that,
Mrs. Thurston Howell.
You think they should say
"Congratulations. Great job"?
I think you're confusing
a press conference
with a party of some kind.
[ As Trump ] Not only
are your questions horrid,
you never bring balloons.
It's been a month.
Not a single cake.
Have you guys not heard
of piñatas,
or have you and you just don't
like them 'cause you hate fun?
Yeah, you hate fun, I said it.
[ Normal voice ] But yeah,
next time we can bring out
a cake that says
"Congratulations on only
17 million unemployed."
Seriously, we could,
because in the last month or so,
we've all gotten pretty good
at baking.
Not great at ironing.
But pretty good at baking.
And then we found out
over the weekend
about yet another
series of warnings
when "The New York Times"
published a blockbuster account
of how Trump ignored the crisis
for months
as well as e-mails from medical
experts and government officials
talking about the danger
of what was happening.
One infectious disease doctor,
James Lawler,
who served in the White House
under President Bush
and as an adviser
to President Obama
wrote in one e-mail that
the government's slow response
was "like ignoring
the smoke detector
and waiting until
your entire house is on fire
to call the fire department."
And in another, he wrote,
"Pilots can tell you
what happens
when a crew makes decisions
based on intuition
rather than what their
instruments are telling them."
Among the many horrifying parts
of that story
is imagining Trump
as an airline pilot.
If Trump had been flying during
the Miracle on the Hudson,
we would be calling it the
"Fireball on the East River."
And he would have spent
the whole time blaming the geese
and yelling at the passengers,
[ As Trump ] You know,
instead of screaming
and putting on
your oxygen masks,
you should be saying,
"Congratulations.
Great job, Captain."
[ Normal voice ] It's going to
make a great movie.
We also considered
sullen and bully,
but we thought in your head
you might hear "bulley,"
and no one wants that.
Again, what we're experiencing
now was not inevitable.
In those same e-mails,
Lawler noted that pandemic
response planning began in 2006
under the Bush administration
and wrote that we could have
followed the examples
set by Hong Kong
and Singapore where
the outbreaks
were effectively contained.
Lawler wrote of the mistakes the
government was making in March,
"We had systematically addressed
all of these and had a plan
that would work and has worked
in Hong Kong/Singapore.
We have thrown 15 years
of institutional learning
out the window and are making
decisions based on intuition."
Of course he threw 15 years
of learning out the window.
That's probably what
his high school tutor said
when they tried to help him
study for the SATs.
Donald, can you read these
vocabulary words for me?
-10,000 known or suspested
gang members.
Advising law markers.
Will not be tolerited.
Distribution of urgenshy.
-[ Sighs ]
I feel as though I've thrown
15 years of learning
out the window.
[ As Trump ] What's a window?
Oh, you mean
the glassy square hole?
Anyway, don't worry, teach,
my intuition tells me my dad is
going to buy my way into Pennis.
[ Normal voice ]
It's not Pennis. It's Penn!
[ As Trump ]
[ Chuckles ] You said "pennis."
[ Normal voice ] And now,
the same president who ignored
repeated warnings
from medical experts
and intelligence officials
about the crisis,
then instead just
went with his intuition,
is once again telling people
he's going to decide
to reopen the economy soon
based on his instincts.
Over the weekend, he called into
his favorite Fox News shout fest
with Jeanine Pirro
to discuss his thinking
for when to reopen the economy,
something he can't even do
on his own.
-I know you said that
the decision that you'll make,
uh, regarding reopening
the country
is probably the hardest
decision, uh,
that you've ever been
called to make.
Uh, when you make that decision,
I mean, where do you go
within you?
What is it that you dig deep for
to come up with a decision,
aside from all of the people
surrounding you?
-Well, Jeanine, I think
it's going to be
the toughest decision
that I've ever made,
and I'll be basing it
on a lot of --
a lot of very smart people,
a lot of professionals,
doctors, and, uh,
business leaders.
There are a lot of things that
go into a decision like that.
And, uh,
it's going to be, uh --
It's going to be based
on a lot of facts
and a lot of instinct, also.
Whether we like it or not, there
is a certain instinct to it.
-There's instinct involved?
Are you making
a political decision,
or are you a swallow
returning to Capistrano?
Dennis Miller joke.
And I hope you'll pardon me
if I don't have a ton of faith
in your instincts.
One of your instincts
was to put your photo
on Trump bottled water.
Ah, what could be
more refreshing
than being leered at
by a business husk?
Oh, that's piss.
I just drank piss.
You don't need instinct.
You have access
to more information
than anyone on Earth
and you're talking about
a global pandemic
like you're The Pickup Artist.
You're supposed to be
the president, not a mystery.
Also stop making it sound like
a big reality show finale.
[ As Trump ]
I'll be making a decision,
and it will be a big decision.
And I'll be deciding whether
to give the final rose
to the Dow Jones or Dr. Fauci.
Fauci. Hey, Fauci.
Fauci.
Fauci, you want to
hear a secret?
Fauci.
Listen up, Fauci, Fauci.
I'm not going to
give you the rose.
Got you to touch your face,
Fauci.
[ Normal voice ] Also, Jeanine,
what kind of question is this?
-Where do you go within you?
What is it that you dig deep for
to come up with a decision?
-Where do you go within you?
There is no deep within him.
He's so shallow, he barely
exists in the third dimension.
If you dumped a teaspoon
of water in a kiddie pool,
it would be deeper than Trump.
There is nothing inside.
He's as hollow
as a chocolate Easter bunny.
He's everyone
in "The Wizard of Oz"
in one package.
[ As Trump ] What do I want?
Brain, heart, courage.
You name it.
Who am I?
You can call me Tin-Crow-Lion."
♪ I'd be President forever ♪
♪ So handsome and so clever
if I only had ♪
♪ A heart, brain, courage,
moral code,
single iota of humanity suit
that fiiiiiiit ♪
[ Normal voice ] So Trump thinks
he deserves congratulations
for his handling of a pandemic
that's left 17 million
unemployed in three weeks
and tens of thousands dead.
And yet he can't even manage
to coherently regurgitate
basic scientific facts
like this bizarre explanation
of how antibiotic-resistant
germs work.
-This is a very brilliant enemy.
You know,
it's a brilliant enemy.
They develop drugs like
the antibiotics.
You see it -- antibiotics
used to solve every problem.
Now one of the biggest problems
the world has
is the germ has gotten
so brilliant
that the antibiotic
can't keep up with it.
And they're constantly trying
to come up with a new --
There's whole genius to it.
We're fighting --
not only is it hidden,
but it's very smart, okay?
It's invisible and it's hidden,
but it's -- it's very smart.
-Antibiotics work on bacteria.
Coronavirus, and there's
a hint right in the name,
is a virus.
You can't use antibiotics
on a virus,
no matter what your doctor
told you in his airbrushed van.
Seriously, Trump is like
a fifth grader
who forgot he had to make
something for the science fair.
You pour the vinegar
into the volcano,
and then the baking soda.
You know what I'm talking about.
There's a whole genius to it.
I don't think I need to explain.
Just look at the poster.
I had the butler make it.
So in the middle
of a deadly pandemic
that's cratering the economy
because the president
ignored repeated warnings,
he's demanding praise
from governors and the media.
But Trump is the not only one.
His obedient allies on state TV
have also been exhorting people
to shower Trump with praise.
-And by the way, maybe it's time
to once in a while say,
"I want to thank the president,
his task force,
and the Vice President
for knocking down every door
and giving us everything
we're asking for."
-My God, is Hannity
auditioning for a spot
on North Korean state TV?
Even Kim Jong-un would be like,
"Dude, bring it down a notch."
Seriously, Sean, play it cool.
I know you want to be
best friends with Trump,
but you're coming on
way too strong.
You can always tell
when an adult man
hasn't had other male friends
in a while
because when they finally meet
a potential new friend,
they just don't know
how to handle it.
"Oh, man, Donald,
we have so much in common.
You want to come over
and barbecue, watch sports,
drink beer, talk cars,
rate girls and stuff?
I got a baseball signed
by Mickey Mantle!
You gotta check it --
You gotta see it!
The Mick!"
But Sean Hannity understands
that you have to consistently
shower Trump with compliments
or you'll fall out
of his good graces.
On Sunday, for example,
when Fox host Chris Wallace
asked a medical expert
whether Trump's late start
to confronting the virus
cost lives,
Trump lashed out at him
with a tweet saying,
"What the hell is happening
to Fox News?
It's a whole new ball game
over there."
After everything Fox News
has done for Trump,
he still complains about them.
The only news show
he wouldn't criticize
would be a topless woman who
reads his tweets without comment
and then fakes an orgasm.
[ As Trump ]
Boob News continues to be
the only fair network out there.
A lot of good work
being done at BN."
[ Normal voice ]
To stay in Trump's inner circle,
you have to praise him
without exception,
which is something Trump's
unwatered Chia Pet Rudy Giuliani
understands better than most.
Rudy actually offered
some advice recently
to governors and local officials
who had been feuding with Trump
over the fact that Trump
has refused to supply them
with adequate equipment,
including ventilators
and protective gear
for healthcare workers.
-A little advice for
the governors and the mayors.
Take the blame when you have to.
You know, if you play
with your boss,
sometimes it's better
if you don't win the golf game.
Uh, he's the boss.
He's got all the resources.
-Great. Thousands are dead,
and Rudy's saying,
"Think of it like a golf game."
And, no, he doesn't have
all the resources.
We have all the resources.
They're ours,
you outer borough gargoyle.
We shouldn't have to be nice
to the president
to get him to give us
lifesaving equipment.
Besides, you don't have to try
very hard to lose to a guy
who cheats like Trump does.
I had a four on that one.
What about you, boss?
[ As Trump ] I had a one.
Wait. Maybe a two.
No, it was a one.
[ Normal voice ] Trump's already
been impeached once.
And now we're finding out
that he ignored
repeated warnings
from intelligence officials
and medical experts
about a deadly pandemic
that's killed tens of thousands
and left millions unemployed.
Looks like we'll have to find
a way through this nightmare
without presidential
leadership...
-Whether we like it or not.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
Wait. Who -- Who let you out?!
Oh, not you, too!
They're loose!
The boys are loose!
[ Children giggling ]
This has been "A Closer" --
[ Chuckles ]
Oh, are you going back?
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
-City Harvest
is New York City's largest
food rescue organization,
and now they're working hard
to support local families
who are out of work
due to the COVID-19 pandemic.
If you're watching this online,
please hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.